here's something different that I think
you'll also find very interesting today
I'm speaking to Rachel stavis who's a
non-denominational Exorcist whose memoir
sister of Darkness is out and it tells
her story of Exorcist training extreme
cases and sort of what it takes to
complete an exorcism so that I'm super
interested in this and I really
appreciate you talking to me about it
how did you even find your way into
being an exorcist well when I was a kid
you know I always like other kids
complained about seeing monsters under
the bed and monsters in the closet and
then you know parents would come in
right and check and say there's nothing
there but for me it never went away
hmm so I've actually been able to see
entities with my eyes since I was a
child I didn't really want to naturally
it was really scary and I thought that
you know everybody must be doing this
until I learned very quickly you don't
talk about it so I tried to push it away
kind of have a normal life you know
become a writer do all all the normal
things and then as I got older it became
more basically impossible to block it
out anymore and at that point I had to
make a decision what am I gonna do you
know am I gonna check myself in or am I
actually going to do something with this
and that's when I decided okay there's
there's a reason right reason for
everything so there's a reason for why I
have this and it turns out it was
exorcism and as an example what what was
something you were seeing a wrecker or
that you see that caused this that sort
of catalyzed this well you know I didn't
really I wasn't able to categorize them
until I started getting older and
accepting the fact that I was looking at
this but I would see very similar things
over and over again so you know just to
just to kind of give some background you
know when people think about exorcism
and they think about entities or what
people call demons they kind of think of
the movies right where it's it's like
one specific kind of demon and they're
all kind of the same and you know you
say their name and you throw some holy
water and it's gone that's not actually
how it works there it's it's almost if
you will a species a
many different species of demons there's
lots of different ones so to make a long
story short right what I was seeing look
like monsters and there are all
different kinds of them there's probably
thousands of different kinds of entities
I probably still have yet to see them
all right but or some that are really
common which people carry very often you
know it's it's not as it's not as
uncommon to have attachment as people
believed so it's very common that the
concept of a demon is associated with
not not just religion in general but
particularly jhin's now I know you're
nondenominational but is there still is
there a religious underpinning to what
you do you know hard to say well let me
put it a different way are you like for
example are you a Christian no you're
not are you Catholic none of these
things okay nominal right but but that
doesn't mean that I don't believe and
work with high being so so let me give
you some background right on this the
way that I work is really different than
probably any other Exorcist or exorcism
thing that people have ever encountered
by a nice because yeah like I work in
energy and frequency right so if you
think about it just just on a logical
level right we are all energy we all
emit an energy every single day and the
way we do I mean we're made up of matter
which has potential energy and of course
you know we consume food and that
potential energy is converted into
kinetic energy but I don't know in what
sense are we energy well so we emit
frequency every single day that's that's
something that actually you can you can
look up you know we have energetic
frequencies that we put out into the
world in from what I work in write the
words actions we're all emitting an
energy that goes out into the world
we're carrying it with us we go through
the world a specific way and it's our
energy signature you know what we carry
and that doesn't change that much
throughout the day so if you you know
have a good day it might be a little
better you have a bad day right exactly
and this is how in other words what what
device can evaluate how that energy sort
of changes throughout the day and and in
what what's the scale of measurement
well we don't really have that
that's the issue so I I work with spirit
that's how I see it they're on it
whether believe in that or you don't is
up to you right so I work with spirit I
work with energies I can see these
energies with my eyes so therefore to be
that exists right so it depend on your
belief system right up so so in the day
when we go out and we have this it's
pretty much the same the only time that
it changes is when we have a trauma
okay when we promise X us and our energy
then dips low we have low frequency
situations that we're now emitting
that's how attachment finds us
attachment works in low frequency and
when you lo can we just define low
frequency we're talking about wave
theory and frequency is like a specific
element of wave theory are you talking
about Hertz as in sort of like an audio
wave or when you say low frequency how
is that defined so for me the way that I
see it it's almost like okay yes it's
it's like what you're saying so for me
when I look at it I can see people's how
do you define this it's not quite aura
do you know what I mean like it's so you
see the energy I'm curios you called it
low frequency which is nice something
that would be detected either orally
like a you are not oo-aah rare a you are
like in terms of sound but the low
frequency you actually see it visually I
see it visually and my my vernacular
where I get all these words i work with
spirit and that's that's the information
that i get when i hear its have given
you this sort of vocabulary that you use
right so in other word do like not
everyone agrees with calling demon
entity right is called an entity sure
you know not everybody will agree with
calling all of this spirit but like i
call it right so it's define it however
you like let's let's just put it that
way god for me it's the perspective to
just help you understand what i'm seeing
I think yeah yeah like what it is and
how I define it might be different for
other people just like people always ask
me when you see entity like the way it
shows itself to you is that how it
actually looks or is that you know
whatever and I don't have the answer for
that right
and only tell this is how this is how it
presents itself to me got it now Rachel
let me ask you this why do you believe
that you have this ability to do
exorcism and it's sort of related to my
other question which is in the Catholic
Church it's believed that Exorcist the
skill of exorcism is a skill that can be
learned on the other hand you have
people who work more in the psychic
medium side who believe that this is
just something that you are born with
and you either have or you don't is your
skill for exorcism more on the Catholic
Church learn a skill side or is it more
on the something more ethereal and and
god-given or whatever term you want to
apply to it well you know I think it's a
little bit of both if you really want to
know like I think there's a certain
amount of like why do I have it right I
don't know I was able to bring it to the
world maybe that's why I'm teaching
people you know what this is and again
like it's not listen I'm not for
everybody it's not for everybody but for
those people who want to receive that
message they get it they other words if
somebody was not sort of open to the
idea that people could be infested by
demons and that an exorcism could cure
the curator relieved that what you do
wouldn't be for them in other words not
necessarily although I do also work in
trauma and pain so you know I do take
that out of the body as well and again
think about something that I see right I
see and I feel so oh how do you define
that how do you measure that's really
hard to say I can't tell you exactly how
to do that but you know if even for
people who've come to me that don't
necessarily believe that they have
attachment or you know and I've had a
lot of skeptics come through here like
it's not for people who are like I'm
totally down for an exercise I do get a
lot of people who are like I don't
believe in this at all but somebody had
a good experience and I'm desperate so
let's try it right so it'll come to you
out of desperation in other words
they're in such a state that they'd be
willing to accept just anything that
might give any sign of improvement that
they've sort of gotten gotten to that
point and they arrived for an exorcism
and on that basis absolutely I mean if
you think about it if you just think
about it
going to an exorcist is everybody's last
resort this this is not first resort
situation right I've tried everything I
don't even know about this really with
me out but I'm gonna give it a try right
it's you know what those are my favorite
people actually to take because those
are people who come in they don't want
to tell me anything right they want to
keep it all to themselves and then
they're like let's just do this and I'm
like okay let's just do it and by the
end of it they're like in shock and in
disbelief that they feel different
really different no so that's an always
the process of the exorcism like and
without I mean we don't need to get into
the full logistics but just so our
audience has a sense of physically what
it is that happens during an exorcism
what's that like for them or for me well
what what are you doing to or around
them okay so that goes back to the
religious question right so I'm not
religious but I do work with high beings
as above so below that's the feeling
right so if we have all these low things
that we're trying to expel then we need
to call in high things to help expel
that right and so I work with high being
so high beings meaning you know spirit
guides master teachers religious figures
you know because that's still high being
all different kinds so that people feel
comfortable so if you come to me and
you're religious you know it works for
you too because that's that's something
that I can call in for you what are you
like you call in a rabbi and he kind of
blesses it like he would matzo or oh no
I mean high being like what people would
call gods with people you know what in
the end of bread angels like Archangels
things like that got it ah that's what I
call it and the way that I work is I
call them into put energy through the
body so and um if you're in a place of
low energy in the body and that's what's
causing that attachment we have to fill
you with the the high being energy to
pull that out to make that come out of
the body right they've got a full of it
yeah yeah during that process you know
we there's other things that go on like
they're you know I have shamanic tools
that work like rattles and things like
that things that agitate that energy I
use specific in senses and burns that
funds the space
and cleanse the energy is it a lavender
persimmon one of the ones you use or are
there like specific ones that are
exorcism approved no we're talking about
things like copal frankincense even
sometimes things like Blue Lotus will
Spain like the blue British yeah some of
it fairly hardcore at home yeah right so
and then how long does this thing take
or last you know it depends on the
entity like I said there are many
different kinds some are more malevolent
and more difficult to remove than others
so some people carry what I call a
trickster which is something that
creates a symbiotic relationship with
the host that's you know sometimes kids
will get that when when they're young
and it'll be something that's an
imaginary friend a genie and deceased
level on an angel yeah and oftentimes
those create you know something that
that is hard to take out right right
they Teknik want it but then there are
some that people have that are just kind
of like leeches like amplifiers of
emotions kind of make things worse and
those are pretty simple to take out so
it could go anywhere from 45 minutes to
several days that is the is the charge
the cost of this different depending on
whether it's a 45 minute in or out or
like a several day session well I don't
charge for it
you don't charge at all no no so how do
you know how do you make a living how do
you pay for the space where these these
are these events are taking place I'm a
screenwriter I've been a writer for many
many years on the same 15 years now yeah
really
are you just cut out there for a second
Rachel you said for 15 years you've been
a screenwriter right yes yes so I I make
a good living I don't I don't charge
people for my services there because I I
actually believe that whenever because
you know look I work on people who are
very very wealthy you know studio heads
rock icons all of these things yeah and
I also work on people who have very
little so I like to have everyone come
in here as equal this is an equal place
we're not we're no different in here
amazing well let's pause there just
briefly we're speaking with nan de nom
National exorcists Rachel stavis and
we'll continue our conversation with her
momentarily I'm continuing my endlessly
fascinating conversation with
non-denominational Exorcist Rachel
stavis her memoir is called sister of
darkness it's out now
Rachel I want to get on to some of the
other elements of this that I find to be
interesting how would you know if the
exorcism has worked well again for me I
can see I can see when the entity is no
longer there I can see when the trauma
and the blocks in the body have been
removed now for somebody else who's not
me right if you can't see in those terms
what I like to go by after that is the
sustainability of what's happened so you
know if you like for example if you go
to therapy right you go to therapy for
an hour but you go you keep going back
and eventually it gets better when we do
this we do it let's say the same amount
of time let's say it's an hour but it
sustains itself so that person doesn't
go backwards necessarily that's not true
with everyone because way free will do
want to do right but for people who were
really ready you can tell and you can
check in with them months later and
they're still in that same space if not
better so what would what evidence would
change your mind that exorcism is a real
thing in other words not that it exists
for you but even hypothetically like
what evidence could could you be
presented with that would make you say
you know what I was wrong exorcism isn't
real the demons aren't real the the
energy that I see visually it's not real
hypothetically what would it take for
you to re-examine that belief I think
the only thing that would make Miriam
and I believe and it's a real long shot
here is if it wasn't working for people
if if for some reason everything I was
doing stopped working for people all of
a sudden then I would be like okay what
the hell is going on well the thing is
it doesn't it seems like I mean if we're
gonna seriously test that I thought and
I'm what curious what you think about
this right if as serious people we want
to test the quote whether it works for
people you'd really need to have a
couple different sort of setups for
test because you would need to do so you
believe you're an exorcist and a client
comes in also believing you're an
exorcist and an exorcism takes place and
then we sort of evaluate their response
but really that would need to be
evaluated compared to bringing in a
client who believes that their service
provider is an exorcist but you would
want to bring someone in to provide the
service who is not a quote real Exorcist
like you who is doing something that
they deliberate they know is not really
an exorcism
so you would want to test that right
because if someone comes in and a non
Exorcist does a quote exorcism on them
and they also have the same so-called
results that would really call into
question with whether this is really
like a placebo effect thing that's going
on and then I'm curious whether you're
also familiar with the phenomenon of
spontaneous remission right which is
that anytime you're testing some kind of
therapy and I would I would call this a
therapy even though I don't think it is
therapy per se there's some percentage
of people whose condition is going to
resolve on its own so you would also
want to have a control group for that
why do you think that that's never been
done with exorcism well you know I can't
speak for for anyone uh-huh like here's
what I say yeah okay there are always
going to be people no matter what and
and I'm not saying that this is the case
here but even when you have something
that's exceptionally scientific and you
present fact after fact after fact about
it yep the reality about people is that
they are going to believe whatever they
want so in other words hold on Rachel do
you think that the science community
believes whatever they want or they
believe what's been demonstrated by the
facts because I think that that's the
important distinction well I don't think
it's necessarily all the science
community but if you're talking about
people on a general scale yeah you're
talking the world population if you're
talking about global warming for example
and you're proposing all of these
scientific you know accuracy is about
what's going on in global warming there
are still going to be people who say no
that's not accurate it's just the
of the world this is how we believe
right but now where I think science
might be different because in science
it's not just about a couple of climate
deniers we can still say well listen
here's what the consensus is and here's
the basis on which it's built so I think
I mean I think my disagreement would be
that you're sort of framing it as any
dissent means that there's not consensus
right but that's not true no no that's
not what I'm saying
here's let me put it this way please I
have no issue if someone wanted to
measure that and do that experiment with
me I don't know what other people or
what other exorcists or what the church
or any of that would allow no no but
it's not so here's the experiment as I
would do it right and I think I'm
curious and maybe maybe this could even
be done sometime you would maybe gather
ideally it'd be a big number right we'd
get a total of 50 people who are in
conditions where they want they are open
to an exorcism and they believe in the
concept of exorcism you would see 25 of
them and you would do your thing and
then like me or someone else someone
who's not trained as an exorcist would
come in the patients wouldn't know
whether they've got the quote real
Exorcist or not the real one we would
spend 45 minutes in with these people
and then we would see does the group of
25 that had the quote real Exorcist do
better than the 25 that were treated by
a fake Exorcist that and then you would
ideally also have another group of 25
who does nothing and we just check in
with them in a month and see how many of
them are feeling better with absolutely
no treatment is that something you would
be open to like do you think exorcism
results would stand up in a test like
that
absolutely you know I will participate
that would be stunning that would be
amazing yeah I've always thought that I
believe that what I do is is you know
not it's somewhere where myth meets diet
let's look that way right and I do
believe that very wholeheartedly well I
don't think that it's been measured I
don't believe that people have spent the
time or put the money in or even if we
have everything we would need to measure
that right but well I don't know I mean
there are like the Randi the James Randi
Foundation has had a long-standing
$1,000,000 prize for anyone who can
demonstrate psychic abilities and I know
you're
you're doing exorcism not psychic
abilities psychic abilities in a
demonstrable scientific environment I
know there are similar prizes for other
assertions and I don't know if I want to
call them supernatural assertions or
sort of pseudoscience or fringe science
or whatever else I make I think there's
certainly the willingness I guess my
question Rachel is if this is real why
hasn't the scientific community embraced
it it's sort of like when people talk
about aliens right and you see you hear
from people who believe in alien
abductions and they go listen David it's
a cover-up because the scientific
community doesn't want it getting out
there bababababa if you meet any
astronomer it would be abundantly clear
that if we had real evidence of contact
with aliens this would be the most
exciting time in the history of
astronomy like there would be no way
that the scientific community would
collude to cover up evidence of aliens I
guess what I don't get as a skeptic is
why doesn't science accept that there
are psychics and demons and exorcism
like what is it why is their interest to
cover that up you know well I I don't
know if they're covering it up I think
they're just predisposed not to believe
it
I think the spiritual world is something
that people are predisposed not to
believe in so yeah oh yeah a hundred
percent look that's the whole thing it's
in this particular world right and this
particular world especially and I'm not
saying this is not the case for other
things but in this particular thing
people want absolute proof ahead of time
right they absolutely need to know that
this exists why because they're
predisposed to believe it doesn't so I
don't know that's true I mean I just
don't think it's true of the science
community I think if you went to the
science community you said let's
actually set up the the double-blind
with a both with a placebo Exorcist and
a control group receiving no treatment I
think you would find science the
scientific community very open to it and
not go in with any preconceived notions
which is the point of a double-blind
test well well listen we should set that
up because I think that it could be an
amazing experience
everybody involved hey let one thing I
want to go back to you Rachel before we
wrap up you mentioned at the beginning
of the first part of the interview that
at a certain point when this all started
you questioned do I go in for therapy or
do I go a different direction which is
to acknowledge that you're seeing these
entities and become an exorcist uh what
made you go one way and not the other in
other words what
what does distinguish this from
something that someone might go in and
seek mental health counseling for well
I'll tell you and I think the answer is
gonna be the opposite of science and
it's faith ah that's so not you know
that's not again that even that is not
for everyone but for me it was about
faith and it isn't that I you know I I
should clarify too that I never
questioned what it was that I had I
didn't think you know I make jokes about
it but I never thought I was crazy now
you may think differently mmm but I
wouldn't evaluate something like like
I'm not qualified to make that
assessment you know well I mean just in
general the general you you know might
think differently but for me I knew that
there was a reason why I had this and
the bottom line at the end of the day no
matter what you believe is that I help
people and if what I have is leading to
help people then there's really nothing
that's that's being done that's harmful
in fact it's making people better and so
regardless of the belief systems behind
that whether you can get with that or
and you cancer is working for people and
even if you can't see what I see that's
the thing that I'm very excited about
and that's the thing that I do and
that's why I do it for free it's because
I want to help people are you able to
sense whether I have any demons or
creatures attached to me well I can't
see you okay so you have to see the
person you've got to see the person in
our do does it have to be in person or
can you do this via Skype uh I can do it
via Skype it's harder for me though to
be honest because I again completely
non-scientific answer here because I
have to tap into that energy a little
harder they're not with me in my space
right so it's got to be like a really
high speed connection in other words
yes for me in my mind yeah got it got it
we'll listen Rachel Rachel stavis
endlessly fascinating truly she is a
non-denominational Exorcist she doesn't
charge for exorcism we've learned her
memoir is sister of darkness wow I mean
I true I think you've said it all and
I'm going to be really processing this
interview for some time and I really
really appreciate you talking to me
about it of course yeah thanks for
having me my pleasure